[Música]
[Aplausos]
eu sou fruto de uma timidez patológica e
tem um verdadeiro pavor falar em público
só aceitei vir aqui por causa de uma
nobre causa
a primeira coisa que eu pensei foi
mandar vir em meu lugar
esse robozinho que está presente em todo
lugar que eu não posso está
tentei negociar mas não deu vai ter que
sair tal a a a população idosa cresceu
tanto nas últimas décadas que a gente
tem a impressão de que tem muito mais
velhos no mundo do que jovens a velhice
que antes eram exceção hoje é vivida
pela maioria e pode ser muito longa quem
tem 60 anos hoje pode viver até seus 90
100 anos e pode passar uns no texto das
suas vidas sendo velhos
essa novidade da longevidade
infelizmente ela vem acompanhada das
dificuldades de envelhecer
depois dos 80 anos uma em cada cinco
pessoas ter algum tipo de demência
um em cada quatro terá perda de visão e
quatro em cada cinco problemas de
audição
a estatística da demência é alarmante
a cada três segundos surge um novo caso
no mundo no brasil já são mais de 2
milhões de pessoas com doença de
alzheimer
provavelmente todo mundo aqui conhece
alguém cujos pais envelheceram e
precisam de cuidado e sabem das
dificuldades que esse filho filha está
passando cuidar de um idoso não é tarefa
simples
quem passa por isso sabe e tudo leva a
crê que a maioria de nós aqui vai passar
por isso vamos fazer parte de um
crescente grupo que faz um trabalho
invisível não remunerado
os cuidadores familiares o bordão deste
século pode muito bem ser cuidador
familiar
um dia você será um ea coisa que é marca
que já não é simples ela pode se
complicar ainda mais
é o meu caso eu tenho 63 anos e cuido da
minha babá que tem quase 90 e vive em
joão pessoa há mais de dois mil
quilômetros de mim e eu conto essa
história da experiência que eu vivo com
o propósito de animar todo mundo que ver
os seus pais começaram envelhecer
precisarão de cuidado a não se apavorar
em a não desistirem antes de tentar e
agora que a velhice ronda eu gosto de
pensar que os mais jovens vão virar
minha história e vão ver no cuidado com
os mais velhos uma boa causa para
abraçar
eu cresci vendo os idosos da minha
família do sertão da paraíba serem bem
cuidados
desde muito cedo eu sabia da dificuldade
porque ouvia minha mãe cuidar da sua avó
durante anos quando ela foi morar
conosco depois de enviuvar não era nada
fácil mas a minha mãe contava com a
ajuda de muita gente empregados parentes
próximos até mesmo a vizinhança ajudá lo
eu já pequena conversava dirá
diariamente com a minha bisavó o ouvir
suas histórias repetidas como se fossem
vendidos pela primeira vez e eu tinha
muito medo porque sabia que um dia minha
hora ia chegar e eu não tinha irmãos com
quem dividir essa responsabilidade
eu era filha única e um dia de forma
inesperada
chegou a minha vez de cuidar eu entrei
num mundo desconhecido sem nenhum
preparo e com muita solidão
uma aventura que eu vivo há mais de 20
anos e que transformou definitivamente a
minha vida é foi muito difícil no início
e no início eu nunca achei que fosse
possível dar conta do recado
acabei dando eu tive uma infância feliz
e normal com pais zelosos e como um
bônus extra eu tive a minha babá a quem
sempre chamei de nenê
a pessoa completamente peculiar ela
chegou na minha casa antes de nascer e
jovem ainda pobre órfã sem documentos
sem idade conhecida e com irmãs que a
vida acabou afastando dela nem nunca
conseguiu aprender a ler e escrever
e esse analfabetismo trouxe muita
insegurança pra ela ela passou a viver
na nossa família
tudo o que significava essencial para a
sobrevivência o trabalho ea família
nenê nunca caso nunca saiu de casa
sozinha nem para médicos nem para
passeios nunca viajo ela tenha medo de
deixar a casa que era um porto seguro
dela nunca andou de ônibus e tenha
verdadeiro pavor
a idéia de entrar no avião o real
talento dela era cuidar e gostar das
pessoas
ela sempre foi babá de todos nós eo
nosso bem estar sempre foi a prioridade
dela eu saí de casa com 20 anos de idade
e deixei meus pais enem
aqui eu me sentia tão ligada quanto a
eles a minha vida
depois que eu saí de casa fui seguindo
um rumo normal casei fui dar aula na
universidade
fiz mestrado nasceu nas minhas duas
filhas
separei sair de joão pessoa minha cidade
para fazer um doutorado fora e voltar
depois que concluir se não concluir e
não voltei não concluir
bom depois veio um novo casamento novo
trabalho e uma vida nômade que me fazia
mudar de cidade a cada 12 anos
mas eu seguia sendo a filha de pais
independentes e ativos
aí há 22 anos atrás veio a primeira
reviravolta
meu pai teve um avc logo em seguida
minha mãe teve um câncer que a matou
meses depois ea minha família que antes
era independente e nunca havia precisado
de mim estava reduzida meu pai é
inválido
a neném sempre dependeu deles num piscar
de olhos
eu tive que me preparar pra tomar conta
dos dois
eu deixei de ser filha única e passei a
ser cuidadora única e não foi fácil eu
tenho que me preparar e entrei no mundo
que era completamente desconhecido e de
completa solidão
ficava pensando como cuidar na época da
minha mãe tudo parecia mais fácil agora
com essa sociedade líquida e as
estruturas voláteis do jeito que era
nada parecia servir para me ajudar
onde estavam as grandes famílias cadê a
vizinhança prestativa tudo havia sumido
havia sobrado somente o desamparo nessa
situação sendo sozinha e morando longe
a solução mais natural era trazê los
para morar comigo mas antes eu tive que
considerar alguns aspectos antes de
tomar a decisão
os médicos me alertavam que terá o idoso
do lugar onde ele vivia podia ter um
impacto devastador
ainda por cima no meu caso as freqüentes
mudanças de cidade e não fazê los passar
por repetidas adaptações como se não
bastasse todos os problemas que eu tinha
eu estava em meio a um tratamento de
câncer
trazê los para morar comigo me dava medo
porque na hipótese da minha morte
talvez ele não pudessem conseguir viver
onde eu estivesse vendo e não tinha mais
para onde voltar
havia ainda a opção do asilo mas pra mim
a criação de novo e china estava fora de
questão
sou idosos sem filhos estão fadados a
essa solução que é considerado um
abandono imperdoável
como não podia largar meu emprego fazer
o caminho de volta pra minha cidade
tomar conta deles
eu tive que me estruturar e aprender a
tomar conta a distância e passaram se
cinco anos eu tive que aprender muita
coisa porque ficava na minha cabeça como
é que vai ser esse cotidiano como é que
eu vou manter uma casa da província a
comida a limpeza e manutenção
é comprar remédios roupas levá los para
o médico província algum lado de como é
que eu vou contratar cuidadores e manter
uma escala de serviços como vai ser isso
bom aos poucos eu fui aprendendo junto
com mais junto com neném foi enfrentando
este desafio e veio a minha segunda
separação nessa minha vida que já não
tem mais nada de normal nem de comum
vizinhos assim por cinco anos até que
veio a segunda reviravolta morreu meu
pai e eu já me sentia mais preparada
para tomar conta a distância mas mesmo
assim achava que pra mim seria mais
fácil e melhor pra ela trazê la para
morar comigo e para minha surpresa ela
não quis sair da casa dos meus pais que
ela considerava como sua e me fez
prometer que eu jamais faria entrar no
avião que ela tanto temia
para sair do lugar dela como ela ainda
tem alguma alguma não ela tem autonomia
física eu achei que eu podia atender o
desejo dela se montar sua equipe e me
organizasse eu fiz isso e fomos
aprendendo
devemos assim por dez anos e veio a
terceira revira volta quando ela já
passava muito dos 80 anos e eu já ia no
terceiro casamento a vida não é só
tristeza viu também a alegria veio a
quebra ela caiu
a queda é sempre o de velhice mudou o
neném caiu precisou de uma cirurgia foi
com o hospital semanas de uti risco de
morte
e quando saiu a sua precisar de cuidados
24 horas
aí não tem jeito agora ela era hora de
ela vir morar comigo mas como a minha
vida não é nada normal e os problemas
andam os montes
eu descobri o meu segundo câncer e aí
outra vez de um medo de trazê lá morar
comigo e na hipótese da minha morte essa
distância estrutura que tinha que tenha
montado
voltar pra ela que agora era muito mais
grave era uma pessoa dele sozinha
analfabeta e sem parentes
então eu tive que pensar em como fazer e
me reorganizar porque a estrutura que eu
havia montado não podia depender mais
exclusivamente de mim não podia faltar a
qualquer momento
e aí depois de meses de negociação com
ela conseguir convencê la a deixar a
casa dos meus pais e morar num
apartamento no edifício onde moravam
duas de minhas primas e suas famílias
foi um sucesso ela se deu muito bem lá
ficou mais segura e eu me sentirei muito
mais apoiada e isso tem sido assim desde
estamos vivendo muito bem mais à espera
da quarta revira-volta como foi que eu
consegui dar conta desse recado de tomar
conta a distância nas diversas fases
eu me inspirei no ditado que diz que é
preciso uma vila para criar uma criança
é preciso uma vila para cuidar do idoso
melhor dizendo é preciso de uma rede de
apoio
eu acabei construindo essa minha vila e
essa rede de apoio ter sido uma rede
formada com solidariedade e colaboração
formada pelos parentes vizinhos amigos
médicos cuidadores provedores de
serviços e produtos todo mundo que
passava tem que entrar na minha rede e
foi ela que me fez dar conta do recado
sem essa rede não teria sido possível
rede de apoio solidariedade e
colaboração
o que eu aprendi sendo uma cuidadora
familiar durante todos esses anos
primeiro sobre a importância do afeto
quem cuida de quem gosta já sai na
frente com muita vantagem
cuidar de quem não gosta de estragar a
própria vida e disse respeitar o idoso
o afeto que eu senti por nenê foi sempre
a grande motivação para enfrentar os
desafios quando não afeto é preciso
criar
sobre o valor do dinheiro obviamente é
preciso construir uma base material para
o futuro há inúmeras coisas que precisam
ser feitas e sem o dinheiro será
inviável
aprendi também sobre o valor da
comunicação é preciso se comunicar muito
com o idoso que está distante e com a
sua rede
é preciso que eles sintam que você está
perto mesmo estando longe
aprendi sobre a solidão de quem cuida
cuidador familiar único ou não
ele passa por um momento de solidão
insuportáveis
você não tem com quem dividir o peso da
responsabilidade dessas tarefas é
impensável
então é normalmente os cuidadores
familiares são mulheres
é preciso convencer a família e trazer
os homens para participar desse cuidado
as mulheres são muito solitárias e
sobrecarregados nessa tarefa
depois aprendi que é preciso cuidar de
quem cuida de quem vai cuidar não vai
ter um cuidado pra quem cuida é muito
comum você ver nas pessoas que cuidam
abandonarem suas vidas
esquecem da sua saúde não têm tempo para
lazer não cuidam das suas finanças desde
com todo o seu tempo e como não tem quem
cuide o cuidador precisa aprender a
cuidar de si mesmo a idéia não é que
cuidar de outra pessoa custe uma outra
vida e finalmente aprender sobre como a
tecla a tecnologia pode ser uma grande
aliada
graças à tecnologia eu consegui realizar
o meu sonho de participar remotamente de
uma consulta médica com neném
eu corro pensei uma empresa que é muito
sensível às dificuldades de quem toma
conta a distância de fazer um sistema de
telepresença é um robozinho a quem chamo
carinhosamente de robot ele me faz estar
presente em joão pessoa
junto com nenê com ele eu posso ir às
compras com ela eu posso passear dentro
da casa com ela eu posso me aproximar da
mesa do jantar sabe o que ela está
jantando
podemos conversar na varanda ela e
roubou e de qualquer lugar do mundo
ambas esquecidas à distância que nos
separa
sem esse robô também eu teria ficado
muito mais longe e mais distante do que
eu gostaria
e qual é a minha mensagem eu fiz de
cuidado na causa
o cuidado de 1/12 a distância poderia
ter me derrotado mas ele me trouxe uma
oportunidade de aprendizagem e eu me
sinto uma pessoa melhor dando conta
desse recado eu quero ajudar a encontrar
uma forma nova de cuidar - solitária e
mais solidária
esse mundo onde tudo é etéreo e efêmero
nele é preciso recriar a cultura de
apoio ao idoso
eu quero envelhecer no mundo um dos
idosos sejam bem cuidados e os
cuidadores familiares bem apoiados a
velhice pertence a todos nós e cuidar
dela é nossa obrigação
[Música]
essa consulta não consulta é super
importante
eu tenho recebido o resultado de uma
biópsia ela estava com suspeita de
câncer de tireóide e se não fosse um
robô de eu teria que ter ido comprar uma
passagem de última hora do rio para joão
pessoa para conversar com o médico então
com o bold eu pude tirar todas as minhas
dúvidas ainda bem que não era câncer não
chega de câncer nessa família e foram
consultas tão natural que é eu daqui
comandando o robô de comer celular
às vezes eu olhava pra baixo pra me ver
magrinha e branca como roubo
obrigada
olá
[Música]